Milan's piazza del duomo normally
bustling now virtually at a standstill
the corona virus outbreak in northern
Italy's Lombardy region means even the
site's historic Duomo Cathedral is
closed to visitors and many here aren't
happy I hope next week they managed to
solve the problem because the
restaurants are empty the cafes are
empty the trams and trains are empty I
don't know how long we can cope with the
situation since the first coronavirus
case was detected in Italy the stock
exchange has plunged 8% making many
worry about how exactly the fragile
economy will cope it's not just tourists
who are missing from this famous square
it's also residents many of whom now
find themselves working from home like
Mara Monti an academic coordinator at a
university in Milan who's trying to keep
things calm for her family so they can
all adapt to the situation the concern
is there I receive messages from all
over the word from my students and over
the world a concern that they are
concerned about me about my situation by
the university my family Mata wants to
make sure her son and daughter take the
necessary precautions by the sound of it
her advice has already made an impact
I always bring my sunny ties in in gel
with me like yesterday when I was having
ice cream with my girlfriends and I made
them all wash their hands at night
Milan looks and feels even emptier
tables with no one to sit around them
waiting staff with no one to serve
before we have much customer boots now
everywhere is dried off even industries
they made sure the sky is dark but so is
the mood yes the trams still run even
though it seems more and more uncertain
where things are heading Mohammed
Abdullah Al Jazeera Milan